the course of the last documents from
Trump's personal lawyer rudy giuliani
have now been subpoenaed for the
impeachment inquiry Giuliani has said
that his contacts with the Ukrainian
government about investigating former US
Vice President Joe Biden and his son
hunter were conducted in coordination
with Trump administration officials
congressional Democrats want to know how
deep that coordination went meanwhile at
the White House Donald Trump once again
suggested he had their time for the
whistleblower protections mandated by
law well we're trying to find out about
a whistleblower when you have a
whistleblower that reports things that
were incorrect as you know and you
probably now have figured it out
the state when I made to the president
of Ukraine a good man a nice man knew
was perfect it was perfect but the
whistleblower reported a totally
different statement and he continued to
attack representative Adam Schiff the
Democratic congressman leading the house
inquiry into the president's conduct
with the Ukrainian government he
actually took words and made it up the
reason is when he saw my call through
the president of Ukraine it was so good
that he couldn't quote from it last
Thursday shift summarized president
Trump's call to his Ukrainian
counterpart at a House Intelligence
Committee like this we've been very good
to your country very good no other
country has done as much as we have but
you know what I don't see much
reciprocity here I hear what you want I
have a favor I want from you though and
I'm gonna say this only seven times so
you better listen good I want you to
make up dirt on my political opponent
understand lots of it and it's this
summary that's been the focus of the
president's anger in recent days Trump
even mused on Twitter where the shift
should be arrested for treason a crime
punishable by death the Democrats insist
their investigations will be Swift
leading to a House vote on impeaching
the president if successful the Senate
should then consider whether Trump is
guilty the Senate Majority Leader
however is leaving open the option of
speeding through a trial so I would have
no choice but to take it up how long
you're on it is a whole different matter
but I would have no choice but to take
it up based on a Senate rule on
impeachment and
chef's meanwhile is expected to convene
his committee later this week Schiff
says he also eventually hopes to hear
from the whistleblower Pierre Berton C
al Jazeera Washington